[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: So today we
have an awesome topic
and an awesome speaker.
So I'll quickly go
over Karthik's bio.
Karthik is a ML eng leading
the data science experience
for Kubeflow and
working primarily
on Kubeflow [INAUDIBLE] project.
Before Google, Karthik was
part of ML platform team
at Uber self-driving
team, and also led
a team of data scientists
in Uber's risk team.
He's passionate about making
data scientists productive.
Having said that, I'll just do
a quick plug for user research.
So one of the things that
we say often in our meet-ups
is this is a
collaborative forum.
We are here to gather feedback
from you, understand your pain
points, or running machine
learning workloads.
So feel free to send us feedback
through the meet-up channel.
You can either post
it on the meet-up page
or send us an email.
We're here to answer
your questions.
And also give us feedback
for the kinds of topics
that you want us to
cover, so going forward we
can make sure that
we pick topics
that resonate with your needs.
That being said,
over to you, Karthik.
KARTHIK RAMASAMY:
Thank you, [INAUDIBLE],,
for the introduction.
Hey all, how are you guys doing?
Good?
So today we are going to
talk about the notebook based
machine learning development.
I probably should have put
that aside too, but forgot.
I put the project
name that we're
going to talk about,
which is fairing.
Before kind of
introducing, I want
to give some context around
what we are doing in our team.
So my team is Kubeflow.
So Kubeflow, if you
haven't heard of before,
it's an ML platform
based on Kubernetes.
Just kind of a raise of hands--
how many people have heard about
Kubernetes or used Kubernetes?
It's good.
Like a lot of people.
It's quickly getting like very--
becoming the standard
de-facto solution
to deploy your
production applications.
So think of what
was Hadoop or YARN
was doing in kind
of 10 years ago.
Similarly, Kubernetes is
kind of resetting the playing
field for how you deploy apps.
And Kubernetes is cloud
native, meaning it understands
the cloud environment.
It understands Docker.
So with all these
things, it's quickly
becoming much more easier
to deploy things at scale.
And what in our
team we realized is
that with the rise
of Kubernetes there's
not much tooling around machine
learning for Kubernetes.
And that's why we started
this project, Kubeflow.
And Kubeflow-- the
aim of the Kubeflow
is to make machine learning on
Kubernetes much more simple.
And I'm specifically
talking about fairing.
Fairing is very focused on
making the goal of Kubeflow
work for data scientists.
How many of here would
categorize yourself
as a data scientist or a
machine learning engineer?
Yeah.
Quite a few, right?
So a lot of data
scientists out there,
they're not really familiar
with the infrastructure
or technologies, and rightly so.
They don't need to know
what Kubernetes is,
or they don't need to
know about resources
or other infrastructure in
order to perform their duties.
And especially when you look at
Kubernetes, and it's pretty--
has a very, pretty
steep learning curve.
So for a data scientist
to spend that much time
to learn about Kubernetes and
able to familiarize with that,
it might not be the right kind
of impactful thing for them.
So what we want to
do is that-- kind
of bring all this
[INAUDIBLE] of Kubernetes
into our data scientist world.
And that means how we integrate
with the notebooks, how
we integrate with our Python
kind of style of programming.
And when talking about a
data scientist environment--
so nowadays, if you
see like Jupyter
notebooks are becoming
kind of the ubiquitous IDE
for data scientists.
There are a lot more
languages-- not only Python.
Like you have R kernel,
you have kind of a--
before you have
[INAUDIBLE] kernel.
Now it's swift kernel.
A lot of new kernels
are coming up,
and the Jupyter notebook
is kind of becoming
a very IDE for data scientists.
So I'm going to kind of show
how we integrate with Jupyter
and give like a very easy
way for data scientists
to build and deploy models.
So before I kind of dive
into some of the architecture
and more complex things,
I want to give you
a very quick simple demo.
That way, you get some context.
So here we are in a notebook.
So our fairing provides
kind of a couple
of different ways of
expressing your training logic.
So I'll go one by one, and
you can see how it works.
So here I am kind of
using this notebook.
But if you are not
familiar with this magic,
it basically saves this
cell contents into our file.
I'm saving a Python
file called train.py.
So this is an example,
but you might already
have a train.py that has all
your training logic, right?
So let's say if you
have that train.py,
how do you go
about executing it?
So I will kind of dive in to
what the back end is later.
But here you can see that I'm
constructing a training job out
of this train.py and I am just
submitting the training job.
So if I submit that job--
ignore all this logging for
now, we will dive deep later.
For now, what is happening
is that in brief,
this train.py is packaged
into a Docker container
and shipped into the Kubeflow
cluster that I'm running.
So I'm running a
Kubernetes cluster on GCP.
So we have a
project called GKE--
just like a Google
Kubernetes Engine--
so that you can go and create
clusters of your choice.
So I already have a
cluster that's running,
and so I am running
on top of that.
So here you can see it just
printed the hello world which
I wrote here.
It's a pretty simple way.
How many of you here
have their training logic
in a Python file?
Like typically have
it a python file?
Yeah a good number of people.
That's kind of the standard
way it works with Git,
so a lot of users
that we see have it.
And even though you have your
main training logic in a Python
file, you still want
to use notebooks
to kind of schedule your job and
analyze the output of your job.
So the second way you can
execute a training job
is through a Python function.
So here you can--
this is just a simple
training job function.
Here, this can be a very
complex function too,
and it can depend on other
functions that you define.
So this is very well
suited for people
who develop their machine
learning models in a notebook
itself, in a notebook
environment itself.
How many of you develop their
code only within the notebook,
not switching to python file,
but within the notebook?
Any show of hands?
A couple there.
So if you're having all your
code in the notebook itself,
you can use--
you can just pass that
function that has your training
logic into the train Java API.
I have to execute this first.
Non-linear execution
of notebooks.
So we can do that.
So it's just a very similar
job of packaging that
into a Docker container
and executing that
into the Kubeflow cluster.
So as you can see,
we tried to kind of
not require the users to
go to another CLI tool
or go to another
dashboard to look
at the logs or other things, but
keep them within the notebooks
environment itself, and kind of
provide you with that workflow.
So here we just executed
the train function.
Then we got output, here.
It cleaned up all the
things that it ran.
So the other set of users--
I'm not sure I
will find it here,
but a couple of our
colleagues at Netflix,
they're very passionate about
executing the whole notebook.
So for example, here
I am trying to execute
a notebook called train.ip, and
[INAUDIBLE] let me open that.
So here, this is a
different notebook.
So I think of this
like you write
the whole, your model
development, in one notebook,
right?
And sometimes that behaves
like kind of a report, also.
So you train your model,
you do some prediction,
you plot some easy curves, you
do some model analysis, right?
So let's say you wanted to
take that whole notebook
and execute it in
the remote cluster.
So that's possible too.
And in order to do
that, we use technology
called Papermill, which is
open sourced by Netflix.
It's a way to execute your
notebook and parametrize
on kind of a schedule.
So far, all these other
things that I executed
doesn't have a
dependency, so it was
executing on a simple
python based Docker image.
Now in order for me to
execute this notebook,
I need to kind of add
a Papermill and Jupyter
to the requirements file.
So I'm just creating a
requirements file with all
my Python dependencies.
So we are going from how
you specify your training
logic to how you specify
your dependencies.
So right now, we
support two ways
of specifying your dependencies.
The one way is to give
a requirements.txt where
you add your dependencies,
and the other way
I am going to show is using a
kind of custom based container.
So if you already
have a base Docker
image where you all
have your dependencies,
you can specify that.
Those are-- specifying
a Docker image
is very useful for
running it on GPU
because for GPU
you need to install
like a Cura and a
lot of other things.
Probably your team or
your company already
have a base image that
has all your dependencies.
So that's a good option
for that use case.
And we are planning to add
a Conda support in addition
to the pip requirements.
How many of you here use pip?
Conda?
Yeah.
I think kind of
equal in numbers.
How many of you use and
have all their dependencies
captured in a Docker
file either you
created or your team provides?
Very few.
That's fine.
Anyways you don't have to
know anything about Docker
in order to use the tools.
That's one of the main things
that we wanted to abstract out.
So here I wrote our
requirements.txt
with Papermill and Jupyter.
Now I can execute
the same thing.
The only additional
thing that I'm doing
is that I'm giving
the input file, which
is all your dependencies,
as requirements.txt.
So now here you can see that it
tries to one that pip install.
Since I already did this, it's
using the cached version of it.
So here you can see it
executed that notebook
and prints out that
non-graphical version of it.
You can also save the notebook
and retrieve the notebook back.
So far, we've done like--
able to specify what
dependencies you want,
able to specify how
you're training logic,
whether it's in Python file or
Python function or notebook.
Now, how do you--
let's see how we can specify
the resource that you want.
So here, this is where
it's getting a little bit
into the Kubernetes
weeds, but we're
trying to kind of
abstract this out
so you will probably see
a better API coming soon.
But for now, let's say
this is the function
that I wanted to execute.
It just prints out how much
CPU I have and memory I have.
So this executed locally.
So it tells me I have
12 cores with 32 GB RAM.
So let me execute the
same thing in a cluster
and ignore this
particular syntax for now.
This is where I talked
about a very Kubernetes
specific syntax.
So basically I'm asking like 90
CPU cores and a 600 GB memory.
So if I go and execute this--
it does like a similar kind
of a Docker building step,
but it's going to
wait for some time.
The reason it waits for it
is that it's spinning up
a VM with those requirements.
So no one wants to kind
of keep spinning like--
keep those VMs right?
Those are like very
big VMs and cost a lot.
So we are using Kubernetes
feature called auto-scale.
So if I go to my
Kubernetes cluster--
and Kubernetes has a
notion of node pools.
The node pools are kind
of the pools of VMs
that you want used
for your workload.
So here I created a node pool
with 96 CPUs and 624 GB RAM.
So this node pool, I
set it to auto-scale.
So the minimum size is zero
and the maximum size is ten.
So if there is no load on
the cluster, it auto scales
that to zero, so you
don't pay for it.
So since I executed this job,
it will create an instance
and start that instance
and run this workload.
So it will take probably like
three or four minutes' time.
So here are some of
the important concepts
that we covered, right?
The entry point is how you
want to specify your logic.
You can specify your
logic as a Python file
or a Python function or class.
We will-- I will show you the
Python class example later.
Or you want to execute
a complete notebook,
you can execute it.
And when it comes to Python
dependency management, we can--
either you can provide a base
Docker image, which is just
very, very flexible, right?
You can install not
only Python dependencies
but also you can install
system dependencies like Cura
or other system components.
And if you don't want
to deal with the Docker,
you can just give a
requirements.txt file
and we will kind of
build Docker ourself.
And right now we have
two types of jobs.
One is called training.
The other one is
online prediction.
The training is very
simple, just takes your code
and run it.
So we have a support for
distributor training also.
I will show that.
And for the online prediction
is where you train your model
and you wanted to kind of
put that into a service
where you can make a HTTP
call and get back the results.
So this is useful for
productionalizing your model.
So once you have the
training of the model,
if you want users of your app
or users of your internal users,
they can kind of hit
this HTTP and point.
Then lastly, I will kind
of dive into the back ends.
I kind of keep that for now.
We'll visit that later.
So let's see what's
happening to the node.
So still waiting.
If I can refresh--
So here, I can see
this, one node started.
So where is that?
So it's still not there yet.
But that's fine.
It will come back later.
So diving into kind
of the architecture
and the implementation.
So we have three
distinct processes
that we go through
whenever we schedule a job.
So the first process
is the preprocessor.
And this is how you specify
your code gets packaged.
So either you can specify
it as a notebook, function,
or Python.
So the preprocessor
handles that logic.
That second step is
the builder phase.
And this is where we build
a Docker image out of that.
And here we are supporting
multiple environments
where you are in.
Right?
So, for example, you can
be in an environment lab,
like a collab kind of online
hosted notebook environment.
Or you are running
your notebook locally.
Or you are running your notebook
in a Kubernetes cluster itself.
So for different environments
we need different types
of Docker builders.
So that's why, OK.
We have a couple of
varieties of Docker builders,
not only just a local Docker
builder, but also remote.
And we'll probably add some
Cloud Build support also.
So in the deployer phases
where we built the Docker
image of your code, and
we wanted to deploy it
into kind of a cluster.
And the job type matters.
For example, if it's a
distributed TensorFlow job,
we wanted to use a TF job
that's part of the Kubeflow.
Or if you want to do
an online prediction,
we wanted to do
serving a type of job.
And one of the aims of
this Kubeflow [INAUDIBLE]
is that we wanted to be
very modular and extensible.
So we expose all these
APIs to the end user.
So if you wanted to
build a different type
of preprocessor-- for
example, let's say
you wanted to kind
of take a notebook,
and convert that into a
Python file and run that,
you will be able to do that.
And also, for example,
if your company
has a different way of
building Docker containers,
you can kind of plug
that inside of that.
And on top of
that, what I showed
is kind of the trained
Java API, which
tries to hide all
these [INAUDIBLE],,
and give you a very
simplified API where you just
give your Python file
or your Python function.
It goes and executes.
So one of the most that we
have is the XGBoost training
and deployment.
So here, we have an
XGBoost training.
So all these cells are
pretty standard cells.
Like here I am kind of
reading a sample data set
and doing some mutation,
like kind of replacing nulls
with some mean values.
And here I am doing
a very simple fit.
This is nothing interesting.
It's just trying to showcase
how you do XGBoost training.
And both the eval and
save are pretty simple.
I'm saving to our local file.
And one more thing
that we are exposing
is kind of a Python
class interface,
where if you wanted to do
both training and prediction--
so you can follow
this interface where
you have to have a train
method and a predict method.
First, let's look at the train
method and see what it does.
So the train method
reads the input,
converts that into NumPy
arrays, and trains that model
with the NumPy arrays,
and does eval and save.
And in the predict method,
ignore these feature names
for a moment.
Those are kind of
extra things that
may not be applicable here.
The main one is that you get
kind of a NumPy array input.
And you're loading
the model that you
saved from the training.
And you are doing prediction
on that NumPy input,
and returning the prediction.
So here I've just written
in the same prediction,
just for example.
So if I wanted to kind of run
this training job locally,
I will just say, house
train dot trained.
Right?
House serve dot train.
Here it's a pretty simple model.
So it executes pretty fast.
So typically, our
data scientists,
they wanted to kind
of train locally
with a smaller data set before
training with a bigger data
set so that their iterations
speed is much faster.
Right?
So here I did that.
I trained locally.
It works.
So now, if I wanted
to kind of do
the same thing on
a remote cluster,
I do some configurations where
I have to store my output Docker
files, and also kind of
creating the Python base image.
So all these are defaults.
I'm just showing it.
But you don't have
to specify this.
It will infer that
automatically.
So we are going back
to the train job API.
So before we gave
a Python function.
So here we are giving
a Python class.
So the train job will
take the Python class
and package that
into a Docker image,
and execute it in
the remote cluster.
So you would a see
similar experience.
So here we are also giving
it requirements.txt.
So this one contains
all the Panda,
scikit-learn, all
your requirements.
So it's going to install all
those requirements for you
in the Docker image.
So it takes some
time to install that.
So once it's
installed, it's going
to push that container to
the remote Docker registry.
So let it go.
So in terms of
frameworks right now
we are supporting
XGBoost and Lite GBM.
And we have support for
TensorFlow in a single note
PyTorch.
Just a show of hands,
how many people
here use XGBoost or
GBM for their work?
More like tabular data.
Right?
And one more thing I
wanted to kind of hear
is kind of the feedback.
Because we are doing
this in open source.
And we wanted to
kind of make sure
that it's useful to a
wide range of audience,
and not biased by either
internal Google use
cases or our customers.
So one of the things
that I'll show
is kind of a distributed
support for Lite GBM.
For the people who raised their
hands, how many people have
kind of a requirement
for distributed
training for XGBoost or GBM?
Or a single node training
is fully sufficient?
So you have a requirement.
Can you kind of a rough ballpark
talk about how many workers
you typically use or how
long your training goes?
AUDIENCE: It's an order
of dozens of workers.
And the training typically
runs for 72 hours or so.
XGBoost.
Yeah.
KARTHIK RAMASAMY: The problem
I can show you that are more--
it should be simple enough
for you to give it a try.
Yeah.
So it's pushing the
Docker image here.
So since I kind of
cleared out all my cache,
it's rebuilding it.
When you typically
do this second time,
it should be really fast.
So yeah.
It did run.
And it's very similar
to the local running.
It's pretty fast.
So there's not much time
to wait for it running.
And the other one that
I wanted to kind of show
is how to do our prediction.
So going back to the
class that we had--
so this predict method.
Right?
So this predict method,
you can call it locally.
But if you wanted to kind
of put it as an HTTP server,
it takes a lot of effort to kind
of package that and ship it.
Right?
So we wanted to kind of
simplify that process.
So here, instead of
a train job, you say,
I need a prediction end point.
And you give this
similar arguments,
like the Python input
class, your requirements.
One more thing
here you are giving
is the trained model from
your previous training.
And that's it.
So if I exclude
this, what it does
is that first it packages
your Python class
around an HTTP platform.
So we use a library
called Seldon,
which is another popular open
source framework for doing
online prediction.
So since I built the
Docker image previously,
this thing came up pretty fast.
So it's waiting for the
end point to be created.
This will take probably 10 to
20 seconds for it to happen.
So then once the end
point comes back--
so you can take a NumPy
array and do a prediction
against that end point.
So let that happen.
When talking about the
distributed support,
we have a support for
a distributed training
for Lite GBM.
So yeah.
So we got an end point where it
says kind of an IP address, end
port, and a path.
So if I go ahead and do
the end point prediction,
it basically calls that numPy
array against that HTTP end
point and gives
back the results.
So there will be more--
we'll improve the API to
be more easier to use.
Like probably giving
back Panda's data
frame is a much better use case.
And you can go ahead and delete
that end point if you want.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm just wondering,
this essentially acts--
yeah, sure.
So what you've developed
here essentially
acts as a wrapper on top of,
let's say, [INAUDIBLE],, or GBM.
So why is it not more generic
to any other, like CAD Boost
or Random Forest?
Why do you limit it to
XGBoost or Lite GBM?
KARTHIK RAMASAMY: So for
single node training, you can--
For single node training,
that's a great question,
but a good observation.
Yeah.
If I were to paraphrase the
question, what I've shown here,
it seems like a generic.
Right?
Like you are executing
a Python file,
executing a full notebook, and
executing a Python function.
Why does it have to be
constrained to XGBoost?
Actually, it's not.
The demo that I'm
showing is XGBoost.
But you can put
whatever you want.
It's not even ML related fun.
The one thing that is ML
related and framework specific
is the distributor
training part.
Because for the
distributor training,
each framework requires
kind of a specific setup.
For example, if you are
doing a distributed training
for TensorFlow, it needs
specific environment variables
to be set up.
If you're doing
for XGBoost, there
are a couple of ways to do it.
Some needs kind of MPA
systems to be set up.
So we are adding
framework specific support
for the distributed learning.
But for single
node training, you
should be able to use
any framework you want.
The other one that
we are kind of--
So what I showed
with the XGBoost
is where it's a Python API.
Right?
So you are kind of using
the Python XGBoost API.
For Lite GBM we
went ahead and did
kind of a native
integration with the CLI
version of the API.
So I will show that.
So a lot of times,
especially for Lite GBM,
a lot of features that
are exposed as a CLI,
that's very useful.
So a lot of users, they want
to kind of use the CLI version.
And here we did kind of a
very native integration, where
so this is the config
that that you typically
use to train a Lite GBM model.
Like this is similar to
an XGBoost model thing.
Right?
Because unlike
TensorFlow models,
the model architecture
is pretty fixed.
So you control only
the hyper parameters.
So here I am giving
all IP parameters,
or configuration for the model.
And here are the input
data and the output
data, all specified
as a GCS path.
So GCS is our Google
Cloud Storage.
Kind of takes care of
all the storage for you.
And the users just go ahead and
do a Lite GBM dot executable.
Let me go through this,
and run this process.
I'll show you.
You don't have to do that
one, because I already
built that container.
So here it's much more native
integration towards Lite GBM,
where you're not controlling--
you don't have to build
any specific Python
class or wrapper.
You just give this
configuration file.
And we are going to execute
Lite GBM with that configuration
file.
The one interesting
part is that in order
to go from a single node to a
distributed node in Lite GBM,
you just change one parameter.
So I will show you the
distributed version of it.
So here, the Lite GBM
itself has a parameter
called number of machines.
So you change that
to-- like here it's
three out of whatever you want.
And when you execute
that with that parameter,
we allocate that many workers
and do the distributed
training.
So this is where doing kind
of the framework level support
is very useful and very fast.
And what we have seen is that,
and specifically why we chose
Lite GBM specifically, is
that in our benchmarks,
we scaled up to
terabytes of data.
And it gave pretty fast results,
and closer to linear scaling.
Let me [INAUDIBLE].
So that's the light GBM one.
Let me try to see.
OK.
So again, here you can
resource things pretty easily.
You can say how many cores you
want, how much memory you want.
And if you say a stream
log is equal to true,
it will stream the logs.
But if you say stream
log equal to false,
you can probably easily put
a fault loop on top of this
and do very basic
hyper parameter tuning.
So if you have 10
hyper parameters,
you can kind of go through
that pretty simple.
And all the model outputs are
saved into a specific GCS path.
So you can kind of go back
and [INAUDIBLE] that files.
So let me see if I
can execute this part.
So all of this are happening
with auto scale enabled.
So if we go back to
that, the cluster
scales automatically
whenever you execute a job.
And it goes back when you don't.
But this seems to
be the same problem.
Right?
So it's like my paths
are not scheduled.
Probably I'm hitting
some limits or something.
So let me show you another API.
So similarly, we have
a separate support
for TensorFlow distributed,
like if you want
to do TensorFlow distributed.
So here is an example
of a simple mnist
TensorFlow based
on the TF 2.0 API.
So here we are using Keras and
the new distribution strategy.
And here I am using kind
of the lower level APIs
that I talked about, just to
showcase how flexibility is.
Right?
So I am constructing
this preprocessor.
And I would recommend
this lower level API
for people who are very
familiar with Kubernetes,
and they want to control kind
of each step of the process.
So you can kind of do
the pre-processing first.
Then you can choose what
builder you wanted to use,
like if you want to use
a local Docker builder,
you can use this.
And so we have a TF Java
API, where you can say,
I want the worker count three.
I'm not using the parameter
server style training.
So I'm just putting the
chief count as equal to 0.
And if you do that--
I think it's still running.
No.
This is completed.
So basically, you can
do kind of a distributed
training with this API.
So we are adding more
framework level support.
For example, we'll be adding
distributed PyTorch support,
and also distributed
XGBoost support also.
There's a question.
AUDIENCE: If I want to use
[INAUDIBLE] for distributed
training, can I
still use Kubeflow?
KARTHIK RAMASAMY: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
You can use it.
It's a little bit tricky,
but you can do that.
Like with those lower level
APIs, you can do that.
There's nothing preventing you.
Yes.
Yeah.
The auto-scaling,
everything was really done.
AUDIENCE: My question is
about hyperparameter tuning.
So I was wondering if you wanted
to integrate Raytune or Katib,
would you do that at
a level of calling
varying functions directly?
Or would there be a train
job at the API level?
KARTHIK RAMASAMY: Yeah.
Rephrasing the
question, how do we
go about hyperparameter tuning.
And you mentioned about Katib.
I don't know about the Raytune.
I'm not familiar.
Is it part of a bigger project?
Or is it--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
KARTHIK RAMASAMY: OK.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
The Ray-- It's part of
the [INAUDIBLE] project.
Right?
So we are working on a better
integration with Katib.
So, for example, if we
take the current API
and write a for loop
around it, it works.
But it launches all
the jobs at once.
It doesn't kind of do
the Kube based training.
Or if you want to
do early termination
or do Bayesian optimization,
you can't do it.
So we are in the process of
integrating that with Katib,
since Katib was a
part of Kubeflow.
we are planning to integrate.
The API would probably
look like something
that we'll keep
the train job API.
But probably you are passing
in kind of a map of parameters
that you want to sweep.
So from your perspective,
we're just launching one job.
But it will be translated
into multiple jobs.
And the parallelism on how
many trials we want to execute
will be controlled by Katib.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
So Kubeflow and ML Engine.
Are they supposed to
interchange themselves?
Are they the same,
on the same level?
Or how do they come together?
KARTHIK RAMASAMY: So
rephrasing the question,
there are two platforms, like
Kubeflow and ML Engine, which
is our managed platform
that we recently
rebranded as our AI platform.
So how does that compare?
I would say it's two
different offerings, based
upon your requirement.
For example, Kubeflow
is fully open source.
Like Apache 2.0 license,
you can run it on prem.
You can run it natively, but you
have to manage your Kubernetes
cluster.
GCP provides managed Kubernetes.
But there's a lot
of things that you
have to manage on top of that.
Right?
Like creating node pools,
creating your ingress erasers,
things like that.
So it's about whether you
wanted to kind of take
care of all those
management by yourself,
or you wanted to have a much
more cleaner API where you say,
I just want to run this job.
I don't care about cluster.
Or I don't care about lifecycle.
Just run this training job.
And give back me output.
So the AI platform
is much more tuned
for that kind of a
managed offering.
Yeah.
From pricing point of view,
also, it's actually the same.
Even in ML Engine, you
just pay for what you run.
It's the GCP pricing,
the GC pricing.
And so I think people prefer--
what we have seen is that if you
need a very good customizable,
like if you really want to
have access to your clusters,
your nodes, probably Kubeflow
will be a better solution.
But if you don't have a DevOps
team that can support you,
ML Engine is a much
better solution.
Any questions?
Now, let me open this up.
So since we talked
about Kubeflow,
let me see the other one.
Yeah.
So this one ran.
Remember the one
that we ran with kind
of a 90 CPU and 600GB memory.
So that ran in the printer.
It has 96 CPU and 614.
The reason why this is
96 and we asked for 90
is that the node that it's
running, it has 96 CPUs.
So it's printing that 96.
Kubernetes usually schedules.
But the node, it has
at least 90 CPUs.
So this one has 96 CPUs.
And if you wanted to kind
of do the same thing.
Right?
Like going back to
the simple example,
if you wanted to do the
GPU one, like, again, this
is very a little bit
Kubernetes specific syntax.
We will probably have
a better API soon.
So here I'm just going to print
out the GPU architecture here.
So again, like if
I ask for a GPU,
it kind of goes and spins up
the node and runs this process.
But since I already am kind of
running this process before,
the node is still alive.
So kind of it prints the
B100 GPU that you have.
So this is another example of
how you can optimize your cost
structure.
Right?
So typically, if you wanted
to train a model of the GPU,
you go and create a
VM with a GPU on it.
You execute your model.
But a lot of times you spent
on analyzing your model
or looking at your data,
at the same time, the VM
keeps on running.
Right?
That's a lot of money to pay.
Typically, people shut
down the VM and kind
of move the data out of
the VM to their local box,
and analyze the data.
But again, that's a lot of back
and forth data transferring
and a lot of hassle.
So with this SDK
what you can do is
that you can kind of
create a very small VM
instance with just a few CPUs.
And you can do all your
analysis, model analysis,
and visualizations.
But when it comes to
actually training GPU,
you can schedule it on
the remote cluster, which
auto scales do your workflow.
So essentially, you
are using the GPU nodes
only when it's needed,
and shutting it down
when you don't need it.
And since it's bringing back the
results and the data for you,
you don't have to manually
transfer any data sets.
Yeah.
This is like a similar
example where I
run the mnist model on the GPU.
Yeah.
There's a question.
So if you want to get
started, I would suggest
going to the Kubeflow website.
So we have very
good documentation
on how to get started.
So one of the ways, just a
GCP dock, AWS, an on prem
even Microsoft dock also.
So if you go to GCP,
we have a nice UI.
Right?
You can spin up a cluster.
So if you go to
deploying using UI.
So we have an app
to deploy Kubeflow.
So that, you specify your
project name and a couple
of other parameters.
So you have documentation
on how to fill this form.
And when you click
Create Deployment,
it will create a
Kubernetes cluster for you
and install Kubeflow
on top of that.
Then you can go to
that Kubeflow cluster.
You would probably get a URL at
the end of this installation.
I'll go to my already
installed cluster.
So this is the Kubeflow
dashboard you will get.
So here, it has a couple of
components I will go through.
One is the notebook component.
So you can actually post
a notebook on the cluster.
So you can say, I need a Jupyter
Notebook with this many CPUs.
And you can specify
any GPUs you want, like
with extra resources,
like Nvidia GPUs.
And it will give
you kind of a link
that you can use as
a hosted notebook.
And also, this is the
Katlib that we talked about,
which is a tool for doing
hyperparameter tuning.
And here you can go
through creating a study.
So a study is basically
multiple experiments
that you do, and kind of find
out the best one you want.
I'm having some hard time
loading the dashboard.
Yep.
So here, you can go and
kind of fill this form.
So this is the current
API that we have.
So again, this is not a very
efficient way of doing it.
Like if you are doing
a lot of experiments,
you don't want to go
and create it manually.
But also, the other way is that
writing the cyaml file, again,
it's a little bit
of a learning curve
and not a very good interface
for data scientists.
That's why we
wanted to integrate
this API into the firing
API where you just
give a Python map.
And we go and search through
all those hyper parameters.
Another big product that we
have are the Kubeflow Pipelines.
So once you did all your
training and experimentation,
now you wanted to put that
into a production pipeline,
you can use this Kubeflow
Pipelines product.
I'm not going to go
very deep into that.
But generally explaining your
machine learning pipeline
has multiple steps.
So here we have a training,
prediction, model analysis,
things like that.
And you can create
production grade pipelines
using this product.
So Kubeflow is kind
of a big ecosystem.
It has a lot of tools.
And fairing is one of them.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
KARTHIK RAMASAMY: Yeah.
So there's a very strong
connection between TFX
and Kubeflow Pipelines.
So think of TFX is
a pipeline component
for TensorFlow specific
things, and Kubeflow pipelines
is for all frameworks.
But we have very good support
of executing TFX Pipeline
in Kubeflow Pipeline.
Any other question?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I can yell.
KARTHIK RAMASAMY: OK.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So maybe I missed it.
I'm sorry if I missed it.
How easy is it to go
through let's say training
on a local machine and
then go to [INAUDIBLE]..
KARTHIK RAMASAMY: Actually--
AUDIENCE: Some back and forth?
KARTHIK RAMASAMY:
All my notebook,
that example I've shown is
running on my local laptop.
So when I kicked [INAUDIBLE],,
it was going to the cluster.
AUDIENCE: How much code
do I need to change?
KARTHIK RAMASAMY:
So actually, you
don't have to do much change.
Right?
If I go back to my
previous example,
so let's say you are executing
this Python function.
This training
function, if you wanted
to do a training locally,
you just have to do this.
And if you want to do it remote,
that's the two lanes of code.
And not much change.
AUDIENCE: So I can have
Docker machine run on local?
KARTHIK RAMASAMY: You
can do it that way.
It also supports a way
to build a Docker image
in the cluster
itself so you don't
have to have a Docker installed
on your local machine.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] to
that same environment.
KARTHIK RAMASAMY: So the Docker
build happens with requirements
that you specify.
Right?
So here, you're
specifying, these
are my Python requirements.
So it takes a vanilla
Python Docker image
and installs those dependencies.
So whether you build
the Docker image
locally or in the cluster,
it's the same thing.
AUDIENCE: Where do set up on
configurations [INAUDIBLE]??
KARTHIK RAMASAMY: So in
this in TrainJob API,
we don't have the number
of nodes parameter yet.
AUDIENCE: Is it used?
KARTHIK RAMASAMY: So this
one is just single node.
It runs a single node training.
It's a minor change,
you will have that.
The one that I showed the
distributor training on
is using that GBM API, and
also kind of the internal APIs.
But we will expose
that externally.
AUDIENCE: Can I still
write my own config file
to specify the number of
nodes and use this somehow?
Is it just a parameter
for this function or?
KARTHIK RAMASAMY:
We will add it soon.
It's probably coming next week.
So then you can
specify, in addition
to the number of
CPUs, number of GPUs,
then you can specify the
number of nodes you want to do.
AUDIENCE: Through
the elasticity?
KARTHIK RAMASAMY: Yes.
The elasticity comes from
the Kubernetes feature, not
the fairing.
So in Kubernetes if you go and
create a Kubernetes cluster--
So if we can see
that one machine
that I had, the very big
machine, it got terminated.
And right now it's zero nodes.
So here I turned on auto
scaling and set the minimum size
to zero.
So then it will
automatically do that.
So that's the feature
of Kubernetes itself.
AUDIENCE: So if you wanted
to add model versioning
to different models that
you run on TrainJobs,
where would you add that?
Would that be at the level
of the Docker container?
Or is there some
higher level feature
that would be available?
KARTHIK RAMASAMY: That's
a very good question.
Right now I'm solving
it in a very hacky way.
If I go back to my thing,
I'm just adding a timestamp
to my model output feature.
But there's one more
project called meta--
Let me kind of show you that.
So we've been saying
this is a big issue.
Right?
When people train
multiple models,
they want to kind of track
and analyze hyperparameters
and [INAUDIBLE] models, right?
So this Kubeflow metadata is
another component of Kubeflow
that's useful to capture the
metadata about your training
job, like how many layers did
you use, where is your model,
how much accuracy you got?
And finally, you're
able to bring
back to your notebook
[INAUDIBLE] Panda's dataframe
and you're able to analyze that.
So this is like a much
more earlier stage.
But you will probably
keep watching this.
You will hear back soon.
AUDIENCE: If I want to
get profiling information
and [INAUDIBLE] so that if
[INAUDIBLE] keeps dropping,
then it get stopped clusters
and [INAUDIBLE] investigate,
is that possible?
KARTHIK RAMASAMY: So right now
you have to do it manually.
There are a couple of profiling
information you can get.
Like, for example, if you wanted
to get a model performance,
that best tool would be
using a Tensor board.
So you will right the
Tensor board logs.
We are working on easy ways
to launch a Tensor board.
Like one idea that
we have is that
when you launch a
training job, you
will get a URL for Tensor board.
You can just go
there and see it.
But right now, if you wanted
to monitor system metrics,
if you go to the job name,
so usually that spits
out a job name.
Cause right now it
doesn't have the data,
because the job is finished.
But usually you will have CPU
disk kernel things for you
to monitor.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But does
this also tell you
the health of the [INAUDIBLE]?
KARTHIK RAMASAMY: Yes.
Everything.
And the feature of
the Kubernetes itself,
like if there is something
wrong with the [INAUDIBLE],,
it will restart it.
And going back to
the model monitoring,
so right now you have to look at
the Tensor board and terminate.
There's a setting
in TensorFlow itself
to do some early termination.
It's not very advanced.
But you can do that.
So that's a pretty good thing.
I will kind of show you
another thing, touching
upon this particular aspect.
So you can actually run
a Tensor board instance
and point that to a GCS bucket.
And you can get all
your training blocks
into the GCS bucket.
So, for example, I will
show you a Tensor board
that we are running.
So that way, you should be
able to see multiple runs.
I don't know.
Some issue.
But there's a feature
where in TensorFlow you
take a [INAUDIBLE] bucket.
And for every run, you log
into that particular bucket.
So then in the Tensor
board, you should
be able to see all your
experiments and compare them.
AUDIENCE: But that
is post-processing.
KARTHIK RAMASAMY: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Can I see it when
the training is happening?
How do I see how it is
progressing in [INAUDIBLE]??
KARTHIK RAMASAMY: When you
do a distributed training,
all the nodes are
training just one model.
Right?
So typically, you only
write Tensor board
logs from one node.
AUDIENCE: But is there a kind
of some MapReduce or something
that will collect the time,
[INAUDIBLE] the information,
or is it not--
KARTHIK RAMASAMY: I
think it's not required.
You typically have the
information on the model
performance on all the nodes.
So you just take one node
and write out the performance
metrics from one node.
That's sufficient.
Anymore questions?
I'll be here.
So feel free to
ask any questions.
Thanks.
Thanks for attending.
[APPLAUSE]